alright guys I'm here with Sam we've got
a lot to talk about and we're gonna try
to get this done in 50 minutes you ready
all right sounds good
awesome thanks for coming thank you
great great to be here what uh what's
your background
so I'm a computer scientist and a
neuroscientist I guess by a background
I'm also an entrepreneur a long time ago
I was doing research at Johns Hopkins in
cognitive science and like vision and
trying to figure out the human brain and
the nature of reality based on
neuroscience I guess and I realized as
the financial crisis was happening that
I didn't know anything about what money
was so got really into money the
definition of money and join up with
some nerds and made some some paper
currencies in Baltimore called the
Baltimore b-note all right hold on you
what yours this 2008 ish alright so not
Satoshi but in 2008 you created a paper
based currency that was used in just
Baltimore or aspirations to go larger it
was intended to be local it was
basically a discount to the dollar in
that region and sometimes it stretched
into Pennsylvania it's still still
around actually but the idea was to sort
of close the supply loops inside of
Baltimore and act like a loyalty point
system there but it's kind of just an
experiment for me to learn about
monetary theory but that same crew of
people is how I got into Bitcoin and
it's permeated in my life shocking that
the people creating their own currency
Bitcoin yeah all right so you do that
and then when the when do you or well
let's go into because then you worked a
couple startups right yeah yeah so back
then I was a scientist basically I was
doing Applied Science stuff did some
some DoD work I did some stuff for like
Lamborghini building biosensors
artificial intelligence stuff like that
and followed this whole crypto world
didn't really know what to do with it
ended up being CTO of a different
company called atmosphere as I was
getting into the startup scene I
realized that service business models
aren't that great but
you know I I co-founded a applied
science company before that ended up
being CTO of this company right right
during that company is when aetherium
got invented and I followed Bitcoin the
whole time but I didn't really want to
make a wallet or an exchange or
something I didn't really see a startup
business model I wanted in that but then
I met Joe Lubin I heard about the the
white paper of aetherium like exactly at
the same time and it just just clicked
that it was a decentralized virtual
machine that would allow programmable
money allow basically decentralized any
application you can think of and it
clicked for me immediately and I knew I
had to do something it all right so when
do you find out when does somebody tell
you about aetherium it was Joe Loeb and
so Joe told you yeah so it was amazing
so I had heard about this thing everyone
from my Bitcoin friends said this is the
coolest thing ever like you got to learn
about it but like I hadn't read the
white paper everyone that tried to
explain this to me I was like what the
hell are you talking about doesn't
doesn't make any sense and so I heard
there was this thing aetherium go to
this meetup and and and you'll hear what
it is and it was it was Joe and me and
maybe 15 20 other people and Joe told me
what it was clicked immediately and I
walked across Manhattan I remember just
in a altered state of consciousness
realizing that the world was about to
change and shortly after that joined up
with him to help build consensus got it
and so many people I think have heard of
Joe but they don't know him they never
met him I said sure just give people
like why did you believe them right like
what was kind of the what was kind of
the reaction that you had to him and now
knowing him really well right that that
you know left you walking across
Manhattan figuring out what life is yeah
I mean Joe you know Joe's a computer
scientist for one and so also being a
computer scientist you can kind of cut
through the [ __ ] of a whole new set of
paragraphs and in one sentence
decentralized virtual machine that
immediately I got it and just from the
level of discourse that was happening in
that initial meeting of just
decentralization removing intermediaries
the fact that it behaves like Bitcoin
but it also has
the ability to program behavior on top
of it just that that concept resonated
so strongly for me and Joe's ability to
articulate that I could tell he really
believed it I also I also knew that you
know Joe basically had come out of
retirement to do this right he was he
was chilling out in Jamaica and he
doesn't need to go have a job but but he
was having the conviction to do this so
we immediately also vibe on neuroscience
actually Joe's also a neuroscientist by
background and so what's up with the
computer science neuroscientist is doing
I don't know man I think what you know I
think I think we share a desire to
figure out how the world works and how
the human mind works and I've you I've
you aetherium frankly and I've you
blockchain as a way to think about the
extension of human cognition and that's
really what I was into it
in from the beginning is that like this
is the expression of the human mind as
is money right and the way to the extent
that the banking industry and the
central banking industry etc is in
control of the way new money gets issued
and created and the way it behaves and
the way we structure financial products
that that determines the course of
people's lives right that you have a you
have a a mortgage you spend your whole
life paying that mortgage back the
structure of how you do that and why you
do that and how that integrates into
your life is determined by some other
people not most people and that
determines how humans behave in mass so
the same things that I think make it
neuroscientist interested in human
behavior could also make them interested
in money and monetary theory and that's
that's where I was coming from I think
partially that's where Joe's coming from
- that's super cool I really like that
the way you describe that all right so
what is consensus right so and we maybe
let's start with what it is and then we
can get into you know some of the early
days and what that was like so currently
consensus obviously is a lot of things
right so consensus we say there are a
few pillars to consensus right there's
there's the the venture studio which we
kept talking census labs and that's
where we we build and we fund we call
synergies between all these portfolio
companies
you heard of like metamath truffle and
fear uh you know kalida etc so there's
that part of the company I can go into
the details of why it's structured that
way later there's consensus ventures
where we you know we have a typical
looking venture fund we also do some
balance sheet investing as well you've
probably seen our investments in like
drum G for instance projects like that
pretty recently we have consensus
solutions which is simultaneously a
consulting organization and also a
digital venturing organization so things
like Congo things like the AMD
partnership that we recently announced
those are deals where we basically
partner with another company or a set of
other companies in the case of like
combo for instance and we being
blockchain tech spurts build out the
tech platform we have some equity or
ownership of that thing and you know
it's basically a joint venture between
us and some other experts in a certain
field or something right so we've got
that we have consensus Academy as well
we have a social impact arm as well
where we do projects that we think
benefit the world and you know a few
other smaller services but basically you
know we're in the business of deploying
capital either in a very hands-on way or
or in a we're in a distant venture
capital kind of way and we're in the
business of helping other companies and
partnerships realize the power of
blockchain technology so lots of
different moving pieces but that's where
our goal set in what was it like in the
early days right because it cuz I've
heard plenty right now I've had new who
have been there and and it feels a
little bit like a revolution right like
hey we believe something in the world
that a high majority of other people
don't believe and if we work together we
can go build this yeah yeah so late 2014
or early 2015
you know is a bunch of bunch of crazy
people in a room bunch of crazy smart
people in a room that I think saw this
thing before everyone else and
I coulda knowledge eyes it too you know
people who solve it oil and steel before
everything else you know it felt like
that it felt like we know something that
the rest of the world doesn't know yet
and some of the smartest people I've
ever met in my life were collected there
and in the very early days of consensus
there were there weren't really the
tools to go get things to market really
quickly right there was Bitcoin there's
stuff built around Bitcoin but if you
analogize it to the internet people
people like to say you know people make
up all kinds of numbers it were 94 95
right now but I would say in the very
beginning kind of like 91 right where
HTTP the protocol had been invented we
knew that this HTTP thing would be
awesome but we don't have a browser we
don't know web server we certainly don't
have AWS and load balancers and all that
stuff yep so you know in in 91 if I
wanted to build snapchat I would have
had to build all those things right I
would have been very capital-intensive
it would have been not something that a
typical venture investor wanted to
invest in right so so but yet at the
same time we saw you know we saw a
snapchat we saw a Facebook we saw we saw
that all the powerful things that could
be built on this that are now being
built and people understand the power of
so how do you build that thing right how
do you build the entire ecosystem at
once was really the question we set out
to solve and so if we had just made a
fund it would have been too early right
we would have just been handing capital
to people that would have had to
reproduce each other's work and if we
had just made one company we thought
that was ill-advised right because how
many people set out to build 50 things
at once and were successful in a startup
company not not many I know of so the
difference is the you know strike the
difference and we decided to build a
company that builds companies and put
everyone under one roof get them to
exchange ideas get them to rapidly
iterate on things and so in the early
days we were basically like you know
there are only a handful of people in
the world don't even understand how to
build an application on the theorem so
let's start building them let's start
building games let's start building loan
platforms let's start building
prediction markets and let's use that to
motivate
in fira and meta mask and truffle all
those things that now everyone else in
the etherium community used uses we
built because we needed them to build
the vision of what we were trying to do
so we said let's build all that stuff
we'll cut it up into into different
companies and projects later for every
successful startup that you come up you
see come out of consensus there were a
bunch of things that didn't work or that
you know we're an idea that some
engineers explored for a little bit but
but didn't turn into a company but that
was the sort of capital e efficient way
to seed an entire ecosystem that we
designed so lots of people working on
the next generation of stuff is how it
felt and there are early days in those
days employees were getting paid in
theater or etherium Bitcoin actually
along really ok but but some you know
some people wanted to be paid in normal
dollars and things like like sane people
money yeah I think their landlords
weren't taking Bitcoin yet no I
you know I actually tried and none of
them none of them really really would do
it but no in the early days I remember
when I first joined up with Joe I I said
you know let's let's let's start this
like you know and I didn't have a hiring
process or something you know he was
just sort of me and Joe hanging out in a
room and he was like I'll just send you
some bitcoins good sure so I think a lot
of the early early days people like
bitcoins as good as $1 if not better to
them yep and so as you guys start this
did you start out with all of the kind
of different you know bodies of work
right so the venture studio and the fun
and all that or was there a progression
as to hey let's start building first
right you just described and then okay
hey maybe actually now there's enough
people in the ecosystem that we could
fund other companies like I'm guessing
it's a progression but utility yeah
certainly a progression when when we
started the way consensus got put
together was really there were a few
companies like like gnosis for instance
was out there
there were some some other smaller teams
that were already kind of working on
something and we just sort of brought
them into the fold of consensus and
started paying them and you know making
some agreements with them about how we
would collaborate and you know like I
said in the very early days Joe and I
sat down and said you know sure what
should this be on paper right should
this be a fun should this be a company
should it be something in between and
and we ended up deciding there should be
a company for the reason that it seemed
too early that you know there weren't
there weren't mature entrepreneurs
everyone would have had to duplicate
each other's work it would have been an
inefficient use of capital didn't really
just make it pure fun and we wanted to
be more hands-on and let people
collaborate and not worry about their
intellectual property getting traded
back and forth etcetera so yeah so those
early days it was really just move as
fast as possible and then as things have
matured you know it didn't even in
2015-2016 especially if you go google
etherium and you google blockchain
applications didn't take very long to
find us so governments fortune 500
companies entities like that started
approaching us and asking us for help
and at first we said you know I'm not
interested in helping you I'm trying to
you know I want to but I'm trying to
make companies here I'm not gonna
consult for you but eventually you know
in my mind we realized and we hired the
right kind of people to basically build
a consulting organization that can take
our infrastructure tools like like you
know we can fear etcetera
take all the things we'd built for
ourselves port that over and build
solutions for different companies and
governments and and that that
organization just become increasingly
professional and more and more so and
then you know eventually the market has
matured to a point where it does make
sense to hand capital to a mature
entrepreneur and not be as hands-on and
that's the motivation for us having a
fund and doing some balance sheet
investments as well so you know over
time it's just as the markets matured
we've hired the right people and and
adapted to to it but yeah but we're a
really adaptable organization we do all
kinds of weird stuff and whatever makes
sense and whatever we'll get things over
the line so we we just acquire the right
and perform in whatever way we think the
market needs
what are you there's plenty of people
who are huge things right and I think it
speaks for itself just how many people
are involved right how much the system
has been built out and a huge piece of
it is attributable to work you guys did
but there's also people who you know
think you guys are crazy and you know
that this is never gonna work that good
yeah well I was gonna say what's the one
detraction that people would have that
you would agree with is there one it's
an interesting question I think if I had
to detract from consensus it's probably
that we're early that's fair you know
this this whole world is yet to be fully
realized and you know sometimes it takes
a while for a technology to reach
maturity and I think we all see it and
we see how important it is and I think
you do too and that's why we're here and
so I think it'll be a while before the
average consumer has something in their
pocket that is using blockchain and I
think it's not gonna be that it's art
it's already the case now that you know
industry players financial companies etc
are starting to use it but but we you
know we've got a long road and a lot of
infrastructure to build and a lot of a
lot of roads to pave even and so if I
were building a company right now I
think it would be a lot easier than us
building it four years ago so that's
that's probably thought with criticism
okay I think that's definitely fair
let's talk about some of the projects
that you guys are the work you guys have
done obviously you guys have done a ton
in Dubai so maybe just give us an
overview kind of what you guys have done
what you're doing now and maybe where
that's going yeah so lots of governments
see applications of Boston technology
things like property rights things like
voting things like identity systems are
pretty important to them so a couple
years ago Dubai the device Future
Foundation basically said they want to
build something having to do with
blockchain right
and they have this great program where
they invite you to Dubai you meet up
with Dubai Holdings as their sovereign
wealth group a bunch of other companies
in Dubai basically try to see what you
can do to get Dubai to the to the future
because that's very much their their
vibe and what they're trying to
accomplish is they want to be in next
generation city and a next generation
Society and so we along with IBM were
named through that process the official
blockchain advisors of Dubai and we
built an office there we started working
with their Dubai Property Group as our
first project as well as some of the
other government offices through a smart
Dubai which runs all their basically
their smart city initiative oversees all
their government services and just
looking one by one to see what we can
block kenaf eye so to say and the first
thing we identified was their property
registries right because a piece of
property hits it gets essentially
granted to a development organization
that thing goes through 20 different
government offices to sign off on the
plan which usually results in literally
hundreds of millions of kilometres being
driven or pieces of paper being driven
around Dubai per year and then and that
eventually ends up in the ownership of
an individual and obviously right now I
think to to people listening to this
that are in the blockchain they know
that asset digitization and you know
custody of assets and and the
cryptographic signing of assets is a
pretty strong aspect of blockchain and
they saw that back then and that like
instead of having a piece of property
that's represented by a piece of paper
that goes to 20 different offices and
then ends up with 50 other pieces of
paper or than you buy it instead why
don't we have a digital representation
of that why don't we have the land
titling and registry system not only on
blockchain and like factum or something
but actually a complete application that
manages that whole process and so we
started building that out for them
and then you know as time goes on we're
just going through their whole
government suite of services basically
and blocks unifying it I joke a lot that
a blockchain is just an assault on paper
there's a lot of paper in government so
that's why people look it there yeah
yeah that's true I mean pieces of paper
are not only bulky and need to be moved
round but put in secure and you can't
you can't fly with million pages of
something and you know you could steal a
million pieces of $100 bills you know a
lot of advantages over it for sure all
right so let's move somewhere else in
the world Singapore you guys have done
some work with some monetary
organizations there and stuff yeah so
the Monetary Authority of Singapore is
an organization that we've done some
work with and you know basically just
worked on some some trading
infrastructure for them you know I think
the work that we did there you can you
can view as porting more fully into
something that we've done recently
called Congo and that's us Societe
Generale city but maybe 10 partners
actually that's a commodities trading
and trade finance platform that we
recently started working on I think that
that's really the full realization of
that and so what that'll allow you to do
is do at first kyc and letters of credit
but eventually you could view that as
solving a lot of the again paper and
efficiencies but of trade finance and
allowing allowing commodities and trade
finance in general to just be extremely
efficient you know and it's an open
platform so that anyone who wants to
plug into it can I think that's really
the future less so than a closed system
that just makes something 1% or 5% more
efficient an open platform that allows
anyone in the world who wants to
participate in trade finance to plug
into it permissionless Lee that's that's
the direction we're going got it and
then you've created some identification
work in Zook yeah yeah so zhuge for
people don't know zhuge is a Canton and
Switzer owns kind of like a state in the
United States and Zhuge is also the
place where a crypt
Valley is a lot of companies are
structured there and the government
there is really sophisticated in their
understanding a blockchain they have
been for a while and so our platform you
port which is our identity management
system on etherium is now coupled with
their official government identity
system so when you go get a an ID card
for a citizen zhuge you simultaneously
get au port ID that's cryptographically
linked to your ID card and you can use
that to access government services
including voting actually and I think a
few months ago they did some of their
first votes on that platform which in
Swiss society is actually really
important to them their ability to
directly vote on decisions is what is a
unique aspect I think of Swiss culture
and they're happy to support that and I
think the eventual goal is we'll keep
adding things to that you know like just
like in in in Sweden you know you have a
cryptographic ID that lets you access
all your different banks the vision
there is lets build a dynamic identity
infrastructure that is more secure than
it could normally be based on blockchain
that will let every government service
eventually be plugged into got it so we
just kind of went around outside the
United States right Dubai Singapore and
Zook what is your perspective on those
foreign governments or jurisdictions
view on liquid crypto right so
everything you're talking about is
enterprise blockchain or building kind
of more applications of the blockchain
technology to solve problems right
Bitcoin right as digital money aetherium
you know the actual liquid assets are
they positive negative agnostic think
that everyone's a snake oil salesman
kind of where they come out on yeah I
don't want to speak for any of the
government so you know just really look
for us like general sentiment right do
you think that most of them are
intrigued or do you think they think
that's all completely you know garbage
and it's kind of the you know not
Bitcoin blockchain type stuff yeah I
think they are intrigued neutral the
positive in my experience Switzerland
was one of the first places and
Switzerland obviously has a history of
being pretty forward thinking and and
privacy oriented in their banking money
in privacy and Switzerland's been been a
hot topic for them for a while yeah yeah
exactly and so so you know the etherium
foundation is structured in Switzerland
and the reason they were is one of the
reasons they were is because the
government there was able to understand
that you could treat aetherium as a
currency even before it was it was put
out and you know this is a time when
most governments had no idea had no clue
what we were talking about and they were
able to go so far as to actually make a
you know an agreement with them that we
would treat ether even before aetherium
had been launched as as a currency Wow
and so that represents I think a pretty
forward-looking view you know in places
like Dubai and places like Singapore I
think they want to be they want to be
societies that that advance to the next
level pretty quickly right Dubai Dubai
is looking for ways to make sure that
they're they're leading the next wave of
economic evolution of our planet that's
why you know you see such new stuff
years ago they were talking about flying
taxis you know years ago they're talking
about about blockchain
and you know they're much more apt to
move on things quickly that then some
other societies that are that are a
little slower and they you know we
already got it figured out so we don't
want to mess it up is the attitude and
in some maybe Western democracies
whereas whereas a place that wants to
move quickly I think they're very open
to the the liquid crypto aspect of it
and I think central banks as well
obviously there was a report put out by
Bank of International Settlements I
believe a few days ago about how
something like seventy percent of
central banks are considering this so I
think you know I think there's a general
attitude in governments that we need to
do something about this we need to have
an approach whether you know I don't
think the you know the US for instance
is going to be the first central bank to
issue a cryptocurrency but at the same
time I think government's would be
remissed they know that they would be
remiss not to consider how they can
integrate this into their existing
infrastructure mm-hmm hey that's fair
all right let's talk about theory oh we
will call out so all of the the trolls
on Twitter know yes and he is bias we
know what
where is aetherium today right in in
your mind kind of what are the pros and
cons or may not even cons just what are
the the things are going well and what
are the things that are challenges that
need to be resolved going forward
sure so going back to like 2014 when I
talk to people about aetherium most
people said that's so ambitious that's
crazy like it's never going to work
right and every year it you know well
you know you're not going to be able to
launch it and then you know the next
year is well no one's gonna be able to
develop any applications then well the
applications one of many users and that
yeah so the criticisms keep moving the
goalposts keep moving and we keep keep
hitting the goals but you know I think
if theorem is at a place where you can
already do basic functionality that
supplants existing parts of the
financial system right
maker died wild wild crazy right listen
shout out to Rick Burton on steam but I
went over there recently and they sat me
down they walked me through this whole
thing I was blown away yeah yeah that's
crazy you know I I basically have
collateralized loans with no human
beings necessary so okay so this is
actually good so maybe let's talk about
what could actually be done applying a
theory um and the functionality to it
let's use maker die as an example maybe
first describe just what is makers
vision and kind of make her die and they
would get into the CDP's and stuff sure
so so maker basically it's a platform
you know the CDP's are the name it's
collateralized debt position on there
it's basically in aetherium smart
contract it exists today you it's it has
a complimentary stable point called die
that represents a dollar right and so
the basic idea is I have you know I went
alone for you know a million dollars I
figure what the ratio is I think it's
1.5 X 2 X so I can put two million
dollars in a smart contract it spits out
a million dollars of die right and as as
the price of aetherium fluctuates that
contract automatically rebalances itself
such that there's always the right
amount of collateral it's in a certain
range so theory and price goes down you
need to put a little bit more theory and
price goes up you can take a little bit
more die out essentially and so you've
got a stable coin and you've got a
collateralized debt position and you
know essentially you're doing something
that normally takes weeks of
conversations and AML kyc and going to
bankers offices and signing things to
get a you know to get a million dollar
loan bait even if even if it's
collateralized now I can do in a smart
contract in a few seconds and in the
part that's pretty crazy about this is
in a normal lending scenario the lender
would have to be a person that would
then have to get information from the
borrower or information on the asset
they're lending against they would have
to have some ability to recover and
liquidate the collateral right
or whatever yep and then there's a lot
of cost that comes from issuing the loan
managing the loan
you know recouping the loan etc in this
scenario you're putting up an over
collateral you know you're putting up
more Caudill than you're taking on the
loan so there's a whole host of the
complexities that are reduced and you're
doing it in automated fashion okay
because the way here's the and I'd love
here's thought about this so maker dye
is a perfect example of I think of
blockchain as simply the foundation for
all of the automation that everyone's
waiting for right it is we're gonna
tokenize all the stocks bonds currencies
and commodities right it is the ability
for smart contracts to execute things
without human intervention no this is
all the foundational pieces you need for
that automation and it looks like these
CDP's are one of the first applications
of that yeah yeah I think that's a
really really clear example and you
combine that with we have a platform
foot open law okay what's it so it's
created by a really great legal team out
of Cardozo law school and so basically
it is a simultaneous English prose
contract that is a legally enforceable
contract that is connected to a smart
contract deployed to aetherium so that
could be something like say I hire an
employee and once a month their equity
vests you know 1% or something like that
so instead of a lawyer having to compute
that and then keep a record of in the
share register of who has what shares
etc and then actually giving them the
shares you know and then you IPO the
company and then you know they have the
shares somehow I'm going to get on to
the stock exchange whatever instead it
is a smart contract that once a month
sends them some tokens that represent a
share to them and that's it we actually
use that in our Joe music platform as
well to manage music right so you know
you could imagine what normally requires
law firms and court systems and
accountants and lawyers to enact just
like just like this this loan that we're
talking about instead you have a legally
enforceable contract with all the right
pros and fallback conditions or whatever
that also automatically executes
you know pretty arbitrary complexity so
I think that that's certainly in the
future that's we're going yeah it is
it's pretty wild
so let's say that this all happens right
and we're obviously talking about it so
we believe what is the reaction or the
possible options that the legacy
financial system has do they jump
onboard or they get completely disrupted
what's more problem interesting question
well you know I like to say it's not
binary right but but what's your take on
that
I mean look at the the logo of Wells
Fargo it's a horse with a carriage right
and that carriage was carrying gold I
did I did not know that that is a
dangerous dangerous thing for me to
tweet so you know Wells Fargo has
obviously advanced their business model
beyond carrying golden carriages and
financial institutions are full of smart
people that will continue to adapt and I
hope that they do in the beginning of
consensus I was honestly afraid that we
would get fierce pushback from the
legacy financial system and I thought
that they would make huge problems for
us turns out you know if you look at the
members of the enterprise aetherium
alliance for instance most of the major
banks are using aetherium
right now and because they realized that
better to be disruptive you know better
to disrupt yourself than be disrupted
and so I see you know especially you
know the like innovators and and you
know young people in banks at first you
know at first it was the sort of
innovation departments and now it's now
it's CIOs and and you know the more
senior people that have finally like
okay yeah I see I see how this could
completely disrupt our whole business
model mmm finally getting on board so I
think you know big institutions big
ships are slow to steer and probably
some of them will fail but you know in
the big medium-term picture too
long-term picture I think you know the
next goldman sachs and then the next you
know maybe decentralized version of
Goldman Sachs has yet to be built and I
think I think there are gonna be kids
you know with a laptop and a half
that make up something that no one in in
you know we're in Manhattan right now
and I think anyone in Manhattan just
gonna even think of and they don't even
know that it violates some banking
regulation in London or whatever and and
and they're not gonna care and they
don't care at all cuz it doesn't matter
and they're gonna deploy that thing and
then people are gonna start using it
right whether it's CDP's own maker or
it's something else that I can't think
of because I'm too old and dumb that you
know a 14-year old is going to make up I
think that's gonna be wildly different
than our existing financial reality and
I don't I think it's gonna happen
quickly and and people aren't gonna be
prepared but at the same time you know
we're helping financial institutions
lots of companies are helping financial
institutions JPMorgan has been really on
the forefront despite what mr. Dimon may
say you know they've been working on
quorum which is a privacy layer for
aetherium you know they're they've been
pushing pretty hard and III see some
real innovation coming out of existing
institutions mm-hmm it is funny because
there's some institutions that don't
want to be associated with this stuff at
all there's something that actually
there's a benefit to being associated
where they want trying to own the
narrative but I don't know a single
institution that's doing nothing and I
don't know a single institution that
said we're not gonna work on anything
else other than this right it everyone's
kind of in the middle and they all have
different reasons for choosing you know
what they do but your point about you
know the next goldman sachs looks
different right and probably has some
stuff you know has something to do with
this ben horowitz recently was asked on
a in an interview you know about mobile
phones and the internet and killer EV
small stuff and he said you know the
thing that people forget about mobile
phones is that it was actually worse in
every single way than a PC except for a
very small number of ways right
and it had GPS it had off camera on it
right it could fit in your pocket like
you know things like that but people
also were saying you know it's less
powerful how the hell am I gonna do I
think his quote was like you know how
the hell am I gonna do my spreadsheet on
that little last screen right you know
that type of stuff and so the the reason
why is important is you couldn't build
uber or lyft
without the phone yeah right without the
GPS and things like that you couldn't
build you know the instagrams and
snapchats of the world without the
camera right and so you know it's he
brings a kind of full circle he says you
know what does a blockchain have that
other competing powers don't have No he
says trust right and I wouldn't want to
get a step further has trust and the
decentralization component is really
important both for trust security you
know whole host of things ensue when you
think it the legacy financial
institution the first word that pops
your head is not trust right like know
we joke all time you know long Bitcoin
short the bankers go it's it's a you
know play on words but there is odd a
distrust and so I wonder how much of
your view on where some of this stuff
goes is reliant on people continuing to
trust institutions versus one thing I
think a lot about is people are just
going to trust machines more than humans
Yeah right to the algorithms the
machines like we vote you know Google
Maps perfect sample you've already given
up right you just hate it smarter than
me can I ask on the street yeah are
there other things you know CDP's might
be a great example where people trust
the algorithms in the machine more than
organizations yeah I think that's one of
the important reasons for
decentralization okay explain that a lot
of people say the word decentralization
and you know some kind of battle cry but
I don't I don't think a lot of people
really understand why that's so
important and and it's for trust right
it's because if no one controls it right
if no one can get an outsized influence
on the behavior of the system then I
know the system is going to behave in
the way that I think it's going to be
here right and this is why you know
going back to a theorems design for
instance this is why Vitalik consider
like DPOs right delegated proof of stake
which is the underlying protocol the eos
for instance and rejected it right
because he felt that 21 deciders 21
validators is not enough to be
decentralized it's not enough that if a
state actor
wanted to go tell them what to do to
censor a transaction for instance that
it that it wouldn't happen right and so
the degree to which you can trust is
dependent upon the degree to which the
system performs in the way that you
think it will and it requires your
centralization so and I agree with you
also on the point about trust that all
of the systems that financial
institutions are part of and the the the
interfaces to them and the regulatory
environments around them are all
designed to produce trust right the
reason why I trust a bank more than a
guy on the street if I hand them a
thousand dollars and say keep this for
me the reason I trust a bank more is
because if a bank doesn't do it there's
a whole bunch of legal systems that cost
money court systems regulators police
forces whatever and that are gonna go
knock on the door and say hey you know
you're violating the law by not holding
that thousand dollars right so I'm
paying for this giant societal machinery
that enables that trust and and the the
shape of a financial institution right
I'm you know I'm looking across the
street at you know a financial
institution like pop you know how many
floors of that building are for
compliance right how many of floors the
building are people whose only job it is
to make sure that they implement the
trust framework that's been mandated or
by our society well how many square feet
are filled with the paper I could really
reduce the rent over there yeah yeah
exactly
and so you know if you can do the same
stuff because it's in a smart contract
in a decentralized platform suddenly our
whole society is a lot wealthier and
happier we can do stuff for cheaper and
we can probably do stuff that you
couldn't do before because right now
those humans can only move at the speed
of a piece of paper and a phone call
whereas a smart contract and articulate
itself you know fairly quickly mm-hmm
all right
so let's switch gears a little bit and
talk about the AMD partnership so these
is really fascinating ready to it
probably actually didn't get enough
attention right they've got some press
but maybe just talk a little bit about
what that is and why you guys are
excited about
they're sure so the project is called
web 3 cloud or web cloud with a 3 and so
Feeny
and this is this is a partnership
between us and AMD basically to produce
the next generation of cloud
infrastructure to run things like
aetherium applications on right and AMD
is an interesting partner because they
produce CPUs and GPUs unlike you know
Intel or in video or whatever theirs
they sort of sit across that boundary
and then you know secondly we believe
that the the architecture and the
workload of the web 3.0 is going to look
a little bit different than the current
architecture and it and it sort of
dovetails with what we're doing with
Pegasus Pegasus is our it's the name of
our client for aetherium 2.0 and it's
also the just the name of our team that
works on that but our client is
different than all the other etherium
clients in the sense that it is designed
for our vision of their being what I
would call state transfer you know
that's a computer science word but you
know basically information can go
between the public aetherium network and
private versions of an ethereal network
that have different characteristics and
topologies right and so you know if you
look at IBM's view of the world right
the hyper ledger fabric view of the
world they're all about selling private
blockchains so me and five other banks
or 20 other banks can all trade
something with each other in this
private version of abortion and they
would argue some people who advocated
that position would argue you don't need
a token you don't need a Bitcoin or an
ether or whatever we don't need crypto
economic guarantees because it's all
inside this private network I personally
and you know to condense this to some
extent doesn't believe that's the full
vision you know and I think you probably
long Bitcoin I don't believe that's the
full answer either right the big picture
is we create a fabric that connects the
entire planet for permissionless
financial behavior right with rules
applied to it like I can write a maker
CDP and I can have a financial
institution use that or a guy on the
street use that
and I can make you know a thousand other
things that look like financial products
that all are just sitting there like a
public good that people can plug into
just like anyone can plug into the API
of you know Amazon or Google or
something right there's just sitting
there you just plug into it you can use
it for something you can compose it with
other things and construct this new
financial reality that just sits on this
fabric of the internet that everyone has
access to at the same time the security
guarantees the requirements for
something like the public aetherium
network are different than say a social
network right I the the security
guarantees and the way aetherium is
designed it's designed for me to be able
to hit let you know send on a billion
dollar transaction and not worry about
whether it's gonna get there right and
that's that's the level of security and
network topology etc of what etherium is
designed for at the same time say I'm a
financial institution that has a whole
bunch of stuff happening inside my
firewall with maybe with a couple
partners or something
I don't necessarily want all that on the
public aetherium network or maybe I want
something I'm doing to farm out to an
Amazon lambda instance which was like on
demand computing instance or maybe I
want that to connect to a an on-demand
storage instance that's sitting either
on Amazon or in my own data center or
whatever what the Pegasus client is and
the enterprise aetherium spec that EA
and Impreza theorem aligns put out is is
it's a way for one sort of one aetherium
client to both connect to the public
aetherium network and also connect to
private things that the enterprises are
used to having in their data centers so
I can have different different
guarantees of trust right like a like on
Facebook doesn't need to have the same
trust as a billion dollar transaction I
can do it cheaper and faster by using
different topologies you know I don't
need to store my movie collection in the
same way I store my account balances
header so different network topologies
can exist on on networks that are
connected to like side chains of
aetherium like loom network for instance
and simultaneously connect to the next
generation of aetherium which is 2.0 and
so we
we view supporting that infrastructure
supporting that sort of state transfer
between public and private blockchains
as the big picture of where this whole
architecture is going and our
partnership with AMD represents our view
that there's a necessity to support that
infrastructurally it's awesome what um
what is the one or two largest
misconceptions about aetherium there
there are a lot of misconceptions I
think well let's just talk about what
would you think the biggest one if you
could clear one misconception about a
theorem will it be the biggest one is
scalability okay which is a huge
conversation point right now yeah right
yeah it's yet it's you know probably the
most important thing that we're trying
to solve right now okay a theory 'm 2.0
is all about scalability it's about some
other things too but you know what most
people don't realize though is that
there are a lot of technologies that
exist right now that already provide
scalability for etherium applications
okay so as I was saying before you know
there are different different
requirements of trust have different
required Network topologies if that
makes sense so what I need to send a
billion dollars to someone I want to
make sure that the network completely
agrees on that right I don't want there
to be any chance that that gets messed
up I want very high security guarantees
and so sending that on the main chain
aetherium is is the way to do that and
that's what aetherium is designed to do
at the same time if I want to send a
like where I want to you know move a
character in a game or something it
doesn't need to be the same as as a
billion dollars transaction so the
solution to that and what has always
been the solution to that but I think
most people just don't realize is that
there need to therefore be multiple
layers of the stack of aetherium there
needs to be you know what some will call
side chains you know or what we call l2
so l1 aetherium is the main aetherium l2
are things like loom network
or things like plasma where you know I
can already get many thousands of
transactions per second on those
topologies where I don't care about
sending billions of dollars yep if their
name 2.0 and you know and even some of
the changes happening right now moving
to proof of stake etc those are all
designed to get main net aetherium up to
hundreds or even thousands of
transaction per second and that's that
timeline is well on its way a lot of its
proven a lot of it too you know on
testing etc so I think most people don't
get into the details of where that is
and they don't realize how far that that
network has already gone even though it
probably won't be on maintenance or a
little more but I think also people just
don't realize that that is never
intended for the like on Facebook and
you were always going to need these
additional network layers in l2 or even
l3 if you look at it that allow people
to have the characteristics they want
right and so the the future vision that
we see is a network of interconnected
side chains block chains even different
things that aren't block chains maybe
even better cryptographically guaranteed
that all plug into the main fabric of a
theory of main net and right now there's
really there's really nothing else that
even comes close in terms of its ability
to have the same trust and security
guarantees in performance so that's you
know maybe that'll bring out some trolls
on Twitter but if you don't got trolls
you're not doing anything all right so
before I finish up I usually do some
rapid fire questions other than
consensus what's the most important
company in crypto that's interesting
question probably coinbase why because
they are what most consumers see as the
face of it and if I were gonna build the
on-ramps for normal people I would start
there I'd start with really good UX
simple enough for people to understand
what's going on simple enough and secure
enough for them to have an identity on a
blockchain
and and get it into their hands so
actually I guess cash up is is actually
more ubiquitous right now for people but
but I think coinbase has a better sense
of what consumers do so they're the main
entry point as it sits right now for
consumers so it's supposed to be rapid
fires but now you got me on what usually
when he will ask me this question I say
Facebook and not because of what they've
done yet but whatever they launched I'm
gonna hit you know it could be 2 billion
people suck bucks or face coin I like
but but it's just it could be the first
interaction that you know 2 billion
people have with blockchain scripto
whatever token whether it's one they
create or somebody else's I mean we're
talking about a pretty important piece
of technology and this is the exact same
thought process it's just that interface
yeah and whatever that interface is that
most people interact with it's gonna be
important if anyone from Facebook is
listening to it you know I hope they do
it in a decentralized way I hope they
build on the existing infrastructure so
we get this network effect on all the
the genius people working on this right
now if they do something closed off I'll
be sad
I'm regard on a limb I usually don't
comment on future future as that people
may do you know but my guess right now I
worked there so I have a general sense
of the internal culture
my guess is very similar to you know
when we think about banks there's plenty
of people that who are excited about
this technology and they want to apply
it and maybe there's some people who
aren't as excited and so slows it down
there's bureaucratic I bet you there's a
lot of people at Facebook that are
really excited about blockchain
technology and crypto provide a lot of
people who participate in the ecosystem
right and I bet you there's a pretty
serious conversation going on you know
should it be decentralized or not right
there's both sides that are probably you
know going and I'm with you that I think
that they're gonna do it decentralized
good it would be
yeah it just it feels like that's the
right thing there's enough people
probably you know having that
conversation how you do it is hard right
when you're kind of a for-profit company
like that and you got some shareholders
and all that but it'll be very
interesting to see what they come out
with yeah I think so
all right um what is the one thing that
you believe that you think a high
majority of other people would disagree
with hmm that's an interesting question
I think that the I think that the part
of of blockchains that ends up on
private architectures if you go and you
know if you go into the enterprise world
of blockchain which I sit in a lot I
think almost none of it will end up on
that I think what's gonna happen is when
people say they want private blockchains
what they're really saying is they want
privacy and and security and maybe some
like composability in control and I
think the the the technology is getting
to the place where you know if you you
put your infrastructure on something
like web 3 cloud we could just describe
with AMD and you know we have ZK snarks
and Starks done and we have a bunch of
the scalability of side-chains done I
think the public architecture the
internet analogized to like aetherium is
way more powerful than the intranet and
I think it's mostly gonna be on that man
I hope you're right all right if you
could change or improve one regulation
what would it be
that's also an interesting question i
I'm going I might hit a hundred percent
here so you know I just speaking for
myself as an individual yeah
caveat it's not a financial advice he's
speaking for himself nothing to do with
consensus i I think that we have I think
the whole crypto token boom has
demonstrated that there's a market gap
for something between securities in a
private offering to accredited investors
and you know
whether it's the Jobs Act or whether you
know whenever we can do it towards
crowdfunding regulations I don't think
those go nearly far enough mm-hmm I
think I think there's this huge market
gap in between and we showed that even
though definitely some people got
screwed and you know the SEC is going
after the people who are scam artists I
think that's good
there's there's a market gap in between
if you look at places like like Wyoming
right now I should the last few days
announced a new a new class of financial
instrument that they want to create some
regulators want to create I think if you
look at some other jurisdictions other
than the US they're treating this like
token stuff as a completely different
class of financial instrument that needs
a new approach not just applying laws
that we wrote in 1930 and and I think I
think we should be doing that I think we
should we should consider how we can
make a new framework that captures the
power of these things and doesn't slow
it down and if you look at you know
people like Hester Pierce at the SEC and
she understands that we don't want to
get left behind and I think we need to
understand how our regulations can
support entrepreneurs better mm-hmm
look it is it's very interesting to see
how a lot of these regulators there's
some that you know really believe and
some who think that the world is ending
and we see it too at the federal and
state level right to your point it has
to appreciate things a perfect example
at FCC who she's been pretty blunt about
what she believes right
if you look at you know the work that
some of the the lawmakers and
legislators and Wyoming write with
Caitlin long and all that and they've
been super open to this stuff and I
don't to push it forward or you even see
you know Josh Mandel treasurer in Ohio
right say hey look bring it on right
let's take four taxes whether he's
pretty interesting what's the most
important book you've ever read
interesting question as well
the web of life by virtue of kapre what
is that it's a book about how living
systems are structured mathematically in
Auto poiesis
which basically means that systems that
perpetuate themselves are good at
perpetuating themselves by definition
right so if you look at evolution
evolution is basically saying stuff
that's good at sticking around tends to
stick around right it's really no more
complicated than that and so systems
that are designed to stick around stick
around crypto you know it perfect
example it's infiltrated our minds and
our financial systems or whatever it has
a sticking power right and that's the
definition of sort of an organism that
has sticking power I view consensus
I view crypto Bitcoin etherium I view
these things as organisms mm-hmm that
viewpoint probably inhabits almost
everything that I've you really
structurally about reality and business
and that book is uh is a take on that
from a deep scientific and philosophical
perspective and it's changed the way I
look at reality interesting do you read
algorithm slipped by I'm not I should
read that it's a tangentially related
but is this whole idea that you know
algorithms in math and how it relates to
a lot of life is a pretty cool all right
so I got one more question non crypto
related and then you get to ask me one
question before before we end so I used
to ask people if aliens had pets
I never we never really think of it that
way but uh I'm just going to stick with
what is the probability that aliens
actually exist
what's the number so there's an equation
called the Drake Equation
okay I've not heard about this all right
here we go check it out and and it's
basically you know the number it makes
sense if you think about what it is
basically the number of stars and the
universe times like you know the number
that hat you know the number of solar
systems that seem to have a certain like
gaseous like characteristic and then you
know how many times out of
you know in a probability space it would
take to make some organic amino acids
and something like that so this is an
equation that people what's the answer I
don't know it really depends on the
inputs but you know my real answer is I
think close to a hundred percent right I
mean I think the definition of life
right is we tend to think is things that
are shaped and sized and move at the
same speed as us but you know if you
look at any system that's good at
perpetuating itself maybe being life
then I think we're deeply inhabited by
things all around us that are a bit too
fast or too slow or big or small or made
out of stuff that we can't see that our
life forms so I think maybe we're just
looking in the wrong place it asked this
question every single guest about aliens
and you would be shocked right early so
I'm shocked how many people believe
there's aliens right like when I was a
kid that was not a thing like it was
like all right shut up kid right you
know one day you'll grow up and realize
this isn't real I mean I believe there's
something out there very similar to
kinda how you just described right and
and there's most people who who has any
sort of logical path to get that's why I
asked the question right it's kind of
whistle logic you use to try to
determine the probability is that it's
pretty cool especially one what uh what
one question do you have for me so many
things let's say what do you think the
next most successful company that exists
looks like so damn it you supposed to
ask me easy one I'm gonna cheat I'm
probably not gonna answer that directly
but it but I'll answer something close
to it so I have yet to see somebody
build an existing large financial
institution from scratch utilizing 100%
of all of the kind of work and benefits
and technique
ecology that is in this industry and
what I mean by that it's kind of like
your Goldman Sachs sample or earlier
right so I don't even know if this is
the right approach to get to the end
result but I think that starting out as
a pure experiment would be very
interesting and so if you look at all of
the functions of an asset management
firm or a bank and you slowly walk
through every single one of them and you
say what is the blockchain of crypto
solution to that and just rip out the
old and put in the new what does that
look like right and I think the easy
answer is like oh it's more efficient
right all that kind of stuff but what I
what becomes really interesting I think
the CDP's is a great example you can
become better at underwriting the risk
you can become much better at recovering
the collateral right in loans what does
that look like with equities or with
maybe some sort of you know income
generating or yield generating type
assets things like on chain you know
equity right where you actually have
just have like an automated claim on the
cash flows of an entity all that stuff
is super super interesting um there's
people working on pieces of it right so
it's not fair saying nobody's working on
it but there's the unbundling Andry
bundling and somebody's gonna come along
and bundle all this stuff up maybe
they're successful maybe they're not but
the person who does that they'll have
kind of an early you know beachhead with
the crypto community because they're
excited by all stuff but if you can do
it in a user experience that is
attractive to everyday consumers I think
you got a shot to you know really kind
of change the way that people think
about money and how they interact with
their financial institutions and stuff
anybody's working on I'd love to talk to
him but yeah well you know now that you
say that I think maybe I formulated the
question poorly because I said the word
company right and and maybe it's not a
company a company can only articulate
itself at the speed of pieces of paper
and boardrooms and votes on
decision-making but maybe it's a set of
smart contracts logic some humans some
not making decisions faster and with
higher complexity than a company
yeah we I priced shouldn't say who it is
but but somebody who I find incredibly
intelligent gave me this kind of
thought-provoking statement they said
what if the companies have the futures
aren't companies but their air traffic
controllers yeah
right and kind of what you're describing
of just you basically create some
infrastructure and you're sitting there
just directing right and you've kind of
done it in a predefined way or a
rules-based way again I don't know if
that's necessary the answer but but it's
it's interesting to think about and
there's probably some potential there
whether it's you know a hundred percent
that way or a piece of it there's no
reason a human or set of humans needs to
be at the top of that thing we I tweeted
yesterday and I had both the positive
and negative benefits of Twitter come
after me
I said algorithms over humans all right
and you know I full well understand that
there's a ton of negative side effects
and kind of dangers right with that
stuff but but I do tend to lean towards
this idea that most of what you and I do
were pretty dumb right and as humans
machines are better addressed they don't
get tired they're not biased right the
repetition and they're smarter and all
that kind of stuff but but also we are
limited by our intelligence and machines
happen to not only be more intelligent
but they can actually learn no no and so
if we can start to apply some of that
stuff I think that you know you really
start to accelerate innovation you start
to accelerate all kinds of you know
different industries we just need really
smart people working on it right and so
that that's the other piece of this is
like what needs to occur for all of this
to come to fruition and the two things
that you know we've come to mind for me
it's like we need time because it's got
a right code right you got to do this
stuff but to is you know I I think that
we've kind of taken our eye off the ball
of intelligent people right intellectual
capital coming in the space 17 we got
kind of the first wave of you know the
people who probably aren't the you know
anarchist type that are gonna be
2011-2012 bitcoiners then you've got
some people in the middle there who are
more computer science right then the
kind of 13 to 16 and 17 knows the first
time that you know you really saw
bankers leave a banking job and kind of
come in right or you saw kind of the
non-technical Silicon Valley folks hey
you know what I want to go do this and
dedicate my career to do it but we need
that to persist right and it's probably
down a little bit because price and the
hype and all that but if we can ramp
that back up I think those are the
things that really matter in the long
term sustainability yeah so long long
blockchain and long humans will be
really been if I start saying long human
short bankers right the only thing I'll
leave you with is that have you ever
seen and I should caveat this - I
actually think that you know Goldman
Sachs is incredibly intelligent they've
obviously you know one of the best in
the water what they do but have you ever
seen one of the octopus things like the
Federal Reserve and all these people say
about that the bank's know it is long
human short the bankers listen thanks
thanks so much for coming this is
awesome we'll have to do it again as you
guys kind of keep going
thanks so much fun that really cool
thank you